well grab your popcorn because biden is
about to set off the squad the
president's upcoming budget proposal
reportedly
won't feature a key campaign promise
wiping out about ten thousand dollars
per person in student debt
something then candidate biden said he
would do immediately
i'm going to make sure that everybody in
this generation gets ten thousand
dollars knocked off of their
student debt as we try to get out of
this god-awful pandemic
so dana does have something to do with
the inflation reports that we've seen
and spending money
i think but i also think it goes back to
what he actually truly believes a while
ago he said something like
the idea that you go to penn and you're
paying a total of 70 grand
a year and the public should pay for
that i don't agree so at what point he
said that and i think that is actually
his probably his true feelings but i
also think that he's starting to bow to
reality
right political gravity is starting to
take hold they're realizing that their
second hundred days will be much tougher
than the first hundred and that this
idea
of student loan forgiveness is a no-go
when it comes to congress however
senator chuck schumer has been wearing a
mask that says cancel student debt as he
cowers in fear of an aoc primary
potentially
so they i don't think the left will
give up without a fight but i don't
think this is going to happen
you know greg i don't understand this
because the left acts like they're for
the little guy
and the lower class but student loan
forgiveness actually overwhelmingly
benefits
wealthy people oh it does it does and
there's this uh fallacy
behind all this that like somehow these
people that you're talking about
are choosing between paying their
student loan and
eating oh my god this is such a hardship
if you look at the average student loan
right it's roughly
the same give or take as a car loan an
auto loan or truck loan
off it might even be roughly the same as
your internet cable smartphone
bill so i don't think people are having
it's
you can't compare it to something like
rent why can't
and i've said this before a sheet metal
worker who didn't go to college
claimed that he wants his car payment
payment cancelled
because it's roughly the same cost and
his truck
is contributing more to society than an
art history degree
by far so why are these people so
special that they can get their stupid
college you know get it off take no that
guy with a truck
he deserves it too then you get to that
point of like okay then what
other loans can you cancel how do you
exactly cancel them
who pays for them you think the bank's
gonna pay for them hell no
it's gonna be us that's why it's not
going to happen
all right juan
well i would just say that education has
a great social value but
i just want to point out that in fact
when chuck schumer
and others said that biden should issue
an executive order he didn't act
he refused to act so what we've got now
is that this
is not in a presidential budget proposal
but remember
the power of the purse is with the
congress so if the congress wants to
pass legislation
that contains this ten thousand dollar
loan forgiveness then
president biden has basically basically
said he's willing to sign it if it's in
legislation that comes from the congress
so congress has that right but i think
that the larger point here is that biden
has other priorities which is the
infrastructure deal
the child tax credit the earned income
tax credit
for the working people i think that he
says that's his priority
not the student debt forgiveness
jesse i don't want to play into the
whole biden versus the squad thing
just makes joe look moderate it's crazy
versus crazy they're both crazy
it's just because joe's a little less
crazy doesn't make him
sane like they're using each other the
squad's saying oh yeah we're progressive
we're pushing this old relic
to the far left look how powerful we are
and biden's saying
i'm not a socialist i beat the socialist
i'm so powerful and moderate
they're on the same team it's a love
fest they control washington
and they can do whatever crazy thing
they want for two years until the
country
throws them out so the squad's saying
let's go crazy for two years and joe's
saying
let's see how much crazy we can get away
with
in two years but this is a problem the
democrats
they created themselves they don't fix
problems they just create problems
slap a crisis label on it like it came
out of nowhere
and then just throw our tax dollars at
it and want credit for being
compassionate
no i like this i don't care anymore
jesse waters
yeah jesse's gonna ban so many topics
we'll have none to talk about
so hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else